There's only two ways to
get out of the Gaza Strip.
There's the north border crossing,
which goes into Israel.
And then there's the southern crossing
that goes into Egypt.
Since Hamas's attacks,
Israel has closed
this northern border,
leaving the crossing with Egypt
as the only way out.
But Egypt doesn't
want to let Palestinians in.
The country is not interested
in housing a bunch of refugees from Gaza.
And they're worried that
because Israel is planning
to invade the Gaza Strip,
if these Palestinians come in,
they may never go home.
So, Palestinians are effectively trapped
in this small rectangle
that is turning more
and more into a war zone.
Joe Biden swooped in
and made a deal with Egypt
to let humanitarian
aid come in through the southern border.
But there's still no news on
whether or not
the Palestinians will be able to leave.
And that is a big question for these
2 million people living in Gaza.
If you want to better understand
global politics, follow along for more.